a whopping three couples got engaged at
three that has never happened before and
host Chris Harrison stopped by today to
dish about what you didn't get to see on
TV will you marry me
are you freakin marry me that last one
Carly saying yes to Evan was one of the
biggest surprises of the season
especially when you consider she didn't
even want to go out with him in the
beginning that kiss was so terrible I
mean I don't understand how this man has
two children Carly said yes to Evan did
that come as a shocker to you
hundred percent let's let's rewind to
the habanero kissing date that I was at
and was hosting the the Guinness world
record date when she was shooting
daggers at me Chris Harrison I'm going
to stab you in the neck for making me a
eat a habanero pepper and B kiss Evan
because I don't like him I wanted to
give him the book she's just not into
you totally so out of the couple's here
I'm gonna make you make the prediction
are they all gonna last repeat
yeah no I'm doing three weddings this
year you are actually for us thank you
right about now Lord and of course we
solve this breakup coming Nick vile is
but announced as the next Bachelor fame
goodbye to Jenn Saviano I felt like I
wanted to say I was in love with you but
for something in my hearts I said I
can't he said I'm the show that I don't
think I can say I love you I'm not sure
if I can say I love you that is my goal
this season yeah he prize you then no
because I think he's just been so
unlucky in love that he feels like he's
a little bit broken and he feels like
it's gotten to the point where maybe
it's not them maybe it's me I have
always been champion for him ever since
the first season Knicks choice as the
next Bachelor came as a surprise to many
and bachelor nation who assumed the Luke
Pell was a shoo-in a source close to the
show tells ET producers were concerned
with Luke's motives saying he seemed
more concerned about his country music
career and how much money he was going
to make than finding love the more we
talked to Luke and the more we got
closer to making the final decision we
just had our our questions as to is he
really ready is he sincere about this
the new season of The Bachelor doesn't
get underway until January but Chris's
hosting duties aren't over yet he's set
to crown the next Miss America this
Sunday along with his co-host ESPN's
sage Steele are you afraid that you
might like at the end up at present a
rose instead of the like the crown right
yeah crowd today there it is I just
promise it will be the most dramatic
pageant ever I knew you were to promise
that so how are we gonna prevent from I
know it was Miss USA The Steve Harvey
did a little mess-up I watched it and I
just got cold breaks for that person
because we've got been there on TV
weren't you gonna do to prevent it Pro
I'm gonna read the right name